[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est un véritable soulagement pour ces
migrants
surnommé dreams ces jeunes sont arrivés
clandestinement aux états unis lorsqu'il
était mineur menacé par le président
donald trump de perdre leur statut
ces personnes risquaient l'expulsion ce
jeudi la cour suprême a validé le
dispositif mis en place par barack obama
contrainte à essayer de l'annuler et
nous avons tous été envahi par ce
sentiment de tristesse
nous étions dans le flou nous ne savions
pas ce qui allait se passer
et aujourd'hui je me suis réveillé avec
la nouvelle que le programme était enfin
protégés et je ne savais pas que
j'allais me sentir aussi excité parce
que maintenant je sais qu'avec l'appui
de la cour suprême nous pouvons aller
vers une immigration équitable nous ne
savions pas à quoi nous attendre
aujourd'hui une mauvaise et une bonne
nouvelle car l'administration preuve
c'est tellement focalisés sur la
communauté immigrante pour essayer de
nous expulser pour essayer de lui dire
de partir de nous expulser
c'est incroyable que nous continuons à
le repousser
je suis venu ici en 2002 quand j'avais
quatre ans beaucoup de personnes savent
depuis toujours qu'elles sont sans
papiers mais je n'ai découvert que
j'étais sans papiers au cours de la
dernière année de lycée quand j'ai fait
une demande de dacca quand j'ai
découvert ça ma vie a complètement
changé grâce au programme bach à ces
jeunes migrants peuvent rester sur le
sol américain et bénéficier d'un numéro
de sécurité sociale élément
indispensable pour étudier travailler ou
conduire aux états unis barack obama qui
a mis en place ce projet en 2012 a salué
sur twitter le verdict de la plus haute
juridiction du pays
les juges ont considéré que la décision
de trump était capricieuse et arbitraire
pour ces sans papiers
un jugement qui déclenche la colère du
locataire de la maison blanche
ces décisions horrible et politiquement
orientés qui sortent de la cour suprême
sont des coups de fusil au visage des
gens qui sont fiers de se dire
républicain aux conservateurs nous avons
besoin de plus de justice
sinon nous perdrons notre deuxième
amendement et tout le reste
votez trump pour 2020 c'est la deuxième
fois en une semaine que la cour suprême
se dresse contre le chef d'état mais
cain lundi elle avait déjà étendu les
droits des salariés homosexuelle et
transgenre
malgré l'opposition du gouvernement un
double revers qui fragilise un peu plus
l'image de donald trump en pleine
période de crise sanitaire et à quelques
mois de la présidentielle du 3 novembre